this feels like the script for something
we're going to go out and try and raise
like 30 grand on kickstarter to shoot
good luck because honestly you're going
to need a lot of it my whole butt is
just wet now
the largest connected empire in history
was the mongolian empire ruled by
genghis khan and one of the reasons it
was able to be so big is because he had
incredible advanced military might
dismounted archers
now horseback archers can basically run
to an enemy shoot them run away from the
enemy before they can catch up to them
shoot them some more while they're
running away and then hold another spot
shoot the enemy some more go back shoot
the enemy and just honestly they just
shoot the enemy 100 of the time enemy
couldn't charge them couldn't run them
down and as long as the enemy didn't
have a castle that the horseback archers
had to somehow try to take horseback
archers would invariably win now we've
done a lot of archery videos and one of
the common things people asked us to try
out was the horseback archery challenge
now we don't have horses but we do have
one wheels
the challenge with horseback archery is
that you are moving when you are
shooting so that when you shoot your
arrow you need to take into account your
momentum because people spend most of
their lives on horseback out in via the
steps of mongolia they learned how to
compensate for that motion so we are
going to do a test to see how accurate
we can be without training three
infantrymen versus two mounted archers
let's see who wins
they're taking a split maneuver okay get
ready split maneuver ready
get him get him get him get him
warm up
up
ah
get off my speed
[Music]
oh no
oh
good job good job you remounted no that
was good
i'm very proud of that shot on christian
at the beginning ah that was those that
wanted it for us
that was difficult for both sides
surprisingly evenly matched i think yeah
i expected you guys to be a lot more op
history has taught me wrong yeah
i'm sorry but weren't the
romans supposed to win the battle of
carthage
today we're going to talk about the
urban zelda script that adrian wrote
it's just an entertaining piece that
winks and nods to zelda fans you know
like i love breath of the wild it takes
a little bit of what we come to know and
love about zelda and putting in an urban
sci-fi setting i would like to see
something like that i'm going to be
honest there's a lot in this script that
i have no idea how we're going to
accomplish it so i'd be interested to
find out how you shoot a rocket at a man
on a motorcycle in the middle of a road
in the post apocalypse
this feels like the script for something
we're gonna go out and try and raise
like 30 grand on kickstarter to shoot i
completely disagree with that a lot of
work to really get this done this is
four days of shooting almost it feels
like it's still a little bit ballooned
here i'm sure you guys are aware of that
i'd love to hear your uh your thoughts
it's a really big issue that we aren't
in the piece then we should have clint
or myself playlist no because it's going
to be cringy this requires a real cast
so to speak i actually think clint's a
very solid actor clint i think you're a
really good actor too but i just this is
not this is not your role like this is
not your role i agree with you sam you
know i mean i i wish this is
unfortunately it's a really subjective
territory we're diving into right now
when i'm saying stuff like that the
video itself to me fits in with the
themes of what we do on this channel all
the time very video game inspired yeah
very cinematic so from that regard it's
very corridor when i was writing this
nick and i both were very aware of like
everything that we put in the script
needs to be capable of us just going and
looking through everything that's like
under this roof yeah and using that
stuff okay maybe the gun you know but
everything else we can probably like
find on amazon style wise the piece is
very much along the corner from a
production resources standpoint yeah
there is some work to be done these are
these are things that are totally within
our means to do so it's not intended to
be a gigantic 30 000 production i mean
if we had to get all the stuff from
scratch we didn't have our connections
and we didn't have the studio then yeah
i wanted to go all out yeah i guess i i
do i can see the cheap way out of this
scrounge around here and we maybe get an
extra airsoft gun or trench coat or
whatever we need you know the production
resources in this are about the same
level as nerf team fortress yeah
i guess so i guess so i'm just like i'm
hitting a wall mentally because i can't
shake the feeling that by going through
that route i'm hoping you're kind of
passing the creative onto my shoulders
let me worry about that and i've gone
through this enough times where i know
it's not going to turn out looking cheap
i learned that i should keep my distance
i should not get too close because
that's going to cause them to try to run
after us do my best not to fall off the
wheel because once you're once you're
off the wheel it is done you are over
you are finished going on either side of
the group when jan was on one side nico
was on the other that was when i was i
felt the most vulnerable so i'm gonna
talk to niko about trying to do that
more do that again i think one thing
that hurt us last time i think it
ultimately led to christian's death and
that last round was we didn't we didn't
form up one thing i wasn't expecting
that is extremely more so to our
advantage is how fast we are in
comparison to them on the ground i
expected them to be a lot faster but
with this terrain they're a little bit
slower than i thought they were going to
be and when they get close enough
it's night night archer
[Music]
oh great
stay together advanced
come
oh it's so hard to knock an arrow in
full sprint
berserker jan
oh good let's do 3v2 okay in favor of
the boardsman so it's like really a can
this happen without me being involved so
so i can like watch from the sidelines
and go oh hey came together cool because
i see this i'm just like
good luck
good luck because honestly you're going
to need a lot of it let's not have a
conversation about how many resources
how much resources this is going to take
until we actually sit down and break
down the resources okay if you want to
keep conceptually talking about how big
this is why don't we actually go through
and figure out what we're going to do as
a team to make this happen i think the
concerns about the scale have been
voiced
i felt the same way about the actors and
stuff too so if you guys feel strongly
that this is on point with the other
stuff we've done in the past then i
think it just comes down to a matter of
going through the script adrian like we
just started and going okay how do we
how do we do this we just did that with
the first two shots
let's keep going all right all their
concerns are definitely valid but i
think kind of going off of what nico was
saying is list problems and start trying
to figure out how you can solve those
problems i think that is the first step
and then if you can't solve those
problems that's when you start to you
know take a step back and try rewriting
being a filmmaker your vision will
always be met with not criticism but
doubt and skepticism that's okay that's
good that means you have people who are
thinking for you because there are times
where you as a director you might see
things in your head and you might
you might not realize you have blinders
on because you're so passionate about
something so it's good to listen to all
angles but at the end of the day it's up
to you to figure out i definitely think
it's doable and i hope it can turn into
something that's really entertaining
i'm simulating accurate armor visor feel
the view here
yeah
now it's a little intimidating
three guys circling you i think we're
just gonna rush
when the time is right you know like a
spider
aggressive aggressive aggressive go go
go go go
get him come on
oh [ __ ]
this is my lane now
this is my room
this is a free land no more
land
i want that free tibet
that grass hot it's free now because
everyone's dead
we all lost something today some lost to
bets some lost just there's no winner in
war
thanks jan for joining us
i i try i try watching friends getting
an idea right now that's it oh yes dude
yes
if you don't subscribe now you're gonna
miss wren breaking that really expensive
360 camera you don't want to miss that
so consider subscribing if you're not
already or as sound like you say ring a
ding ding that bell boys
[Applause]
this month is a very special month
because we have more patreon vips
this month than we've ever had before we
have 14 people who have said we love
corridor digital so much we're going to
go above and beyond
and we're going to support you big time
seth the mad scientist gandalf richard
linder amelia morin rory g squared so
hot live
taylor dunbar colin heaton mitch plensky
you guys are back every month thank you
so much and of course glitch cube james
bailey richard blackburn
and brian antoji every month you go
above and beyond i can't tell you what
it means to me actually i can you know
you know that intern peter
that little uh that bright-eyed and
bushy now this thing is full
because we've had so much love and
support on patreon this year we were
able to support financially his short
film the spider-man one
in addition to that a few years ago we
were able to put air conditioning in our
studio because of patreon
you know gabe our friendly homeboy
designer who's always like smirking in
the corner whenever we're making jokes
yep
you guys helped pay for his salary
our friend adrian remember when he
jumped over that plastic table and broke
his collarbone we wouldn't have been
able to afford that plastic table if it
wasn't for patreon
that's not true we would have been able
to afford the plastic table but
the gas to the hospital the gas to the
hospital i don't know
everything we do here so once again
thank you if you're interested in
becoming a patreon vip you know where to
go go to patreon.com
even just one dollar helps all this so
show us your support or just uh
subscribe to our videos that's also
really cool
consider it
ugh